everything we've done with polynomials
so far has been either adding or
multiplying them but what if we wanted
to go the other way what if we actually
wanted to factor a polynomial let me
show you what I mean
so let's say have the polynomial 3x to
the third power minus 21x
when I say factor it I essentially want
to break it up into the product of maybe
polynomials it could be a monomial which
is just one term and to do that over
here let's see we could factor out we
could factor out a 3x here so if you
factor out a 3x this is equal to 3x
times what's 3 X to the third divided by
3x this is let me write it this way
actually this is the same thing as 3x
times 1 over 3x times the 3 X to the
third minus 21x notice 3x times 1 over
3x I'm not changing the number this is
3x over 3x this is 1 but the reason why
I picked 3x is because I saw that both
of these terms are divisible by 3x and
you're going to see that when I just
when I divide both of them by 3x so this
is going to be the same thing as 3x
times 3x to the third over 3x minus 21x
over 3x and now this is going to be
equal to 3x what's this first term equal
to the 3s cancel out X to the third
divided by X we learned in our exponent
rules you could just subtract the
exponents there that's x times X times X
divided by X it's just going to be x
times X or just x squared so it's going
to be this first term here is just going
to be an x squared and then the X is
canceled out here 21 divided by 3 is 7 x
squared minus 7 and if you multiply them
out you're going to see you're going to
get 3 X to the third minus 21 X now I
went through all of these steps really
just to show you exactly what I'm doing
but as we progress you're going to see
that you can your brain will just
automatically say hey both of these are
divisible by 3 X let me factor out a 3x
and then divide both of these terms by 3
X to get x squared
- seven let's do another one let's say
we had 4x to the 3rd + 10 x squared
minus 2x so when I look at this
immediately what pops out is that all of
these terms are divisible by 2 and all
of them are divisible by X so let me
factor out a 2x so this is equal to 2x
times and when we factor out a 2x let's
divide each of these terms by 2x 4x
third divided by 2x 4 divided by 2 is 2
and then X third divided by X is x
squared and then we have plus 10x
squared divided by 10 by 2x 10 divided
by 2 is 5 x squared divided by X is X
and then finally negative 2x divided by
2x is just negative 1 and if you want to
you know if you don't believe me just
multiply this out distribute the 2x and
you will get exactly this all we see we
try to look for something that's
divisible into every term we factor it
out factoring it out we put it outside
of a parenthesis so to speak and then we
divide each of those terms by that
factor and we did that explicitly up
here now you're probably saying hey Sal
why are even we even worried about doing
this and the answer is is it really
helps us solve a lot of certain types of
polynomial equations let me show you let
me show you what I mean let's say we
have the polynomial equation 9x squared
is equal to 27 X and we want to make
sure that we get all of the X's that
satisfy this equation so let me subtract
27 X from both sides so let me subtract
27 X from both sides so I get something
that equals 0 and this will be a general
trend whenever you're doing polynomial
equations very oftentimes you will the
left-hand side becomes 9x squared - 27 X
the right-hand side becomes 0 and now
over here we can see that both of
these terms are divisible by 9x right 27
is divided by divisible by 9 so is 9 and
then both divisible by X so let's factor
out let's factor out a 9 X so 9x squared
divided by 9x is just an X and then 27 X
divided by 9x that's 27 negative 27 over
9 is negative 3 and then the X divided
by X is just a 1 so this is 9x times X
minus 3 you can multiply it out to
verify that these are the same thing is
going to be equal to 0 now this part is
interesting when I take the product of
two numbers and I say they're equal to 0
let me do a little aside here if I were
to tell you that a times B is equal to 0
what does that tell us that tells us
that either A or B or both are 0 at
least one of these two have to be 0
maybe both of them are going to be equal
to 0 so we're doing the exact same thing
here we're taking the product you could
view that as a you could view that as B
we're taking the product of two numbers
and saying that that product is equal to
0 so that tells us that either 9x is
going to be equal to 0 or X minus 3 is
going to be equal to 0 either of these
or both of these are going to equal to 0
this we know how to solve divide both
sides by 9 you get X is equal to 0 this
we know how to solve add 3 to both sides
add 3 to both sides and you're left with
X because these cancel out is equal to 3
so this equation here actually had two
solutions X could be 0 and you can
verify that 0 is equal to 0 or X could
be equal to 3 9 times 9 is the same
thing as 27 times 3 and you might have
been able to figure that out in your
head but when you do it this way you
make sure that you get all of the
solutions to the problem let's do one
more like this let's say I had 4a
squared plus a is equal to 0 once again
we can factor it
a out both of these terms are divisible
by a so this is the same thing as a
times for a plus one right I'm going to
factor an a out I took the a out of the
parentheses and then I divide each of
these terms by a and that's going to be
equal to zero so that means either a is
equal to zero or for a plus one is equal
to zero well that's one solution right
from the get-go and this one right here
we could subtract one from both sides we
get four a is equal to negative one and
then you could divide both sides by four
and we get a is equal to negative one
over four now I said that was the last
so let me do one more because I want to
show you you know here I'm factoring and
then solute solving but I want to show
you how useful a factored a factored
polynomial is so I'm going to start with
one that's already factored so say I had
X minus five times 2x plus 7 times 3x
minus four is equal to zero and if
you're bored you can actually multiply
these out and you'll find that you get a
third-degree polynomial and but if you
wanted to solve that being equal to zero
would be very difficult but this we're
going to see is not too bad as we said
if we have three numbers if we have a
times B times C equal to zero that means
that at least one of these are zero
maybe more than one either A or B or C
or some combination of them or equal to
zero so once again I have three numbers
this could be viewed as an A this could
be viewed as a B this could be viewed as
a C I'm multiplying them and they're
equal to zero so that means that either
X minus 5 is equal to 0 or 2x plus 7 is
equal to 0 or 3x minus 4 is equal to 0
and we can solve each of these
independently add 5 to both sides of
this equation and you get X is equal to
5 so that's one solution to this
equation over here subtract 7 from both
sides you get 2x is equal to negative 7
divide both sides by 2 you get X is
equal to negative 7 over 2 that's
another solution
and then finally add four to both sides
of this equation you get three X is
equal to four divide both sides by 3 you
get X is equal to 4/3 so this third
degree polynomial if you were to
multiply it out actually had three
solutions to that polynomial equaling
zero and we're going to see these are
actually called roots of the polynomial
the x-values that make that polynomial
equal to 0 but hopefully you've just got
an appreciation for one how to factor a
polynomial in this video and also why
it's useful for solving polynomial
equations